welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast today's show
begins with a good news segment followed
by a very impressive feats of strength
segment after that we have a pretty long
discussion about a recent stronger by
science article that got published the
the article itself was about betaine
supplementation and we do talk
specifically about the conclusions of
that article but we also have a much
broader conversation the body of betaine
research is really just getting started
there's not nearly enough evidence to
have a very very strong conclusion so
our broader conversation talks a little
bit about what it takes for us to decide
that something is worth trying whether
it's a training strategy or a supplement
whatever it is we also talked a little
bit about how much evidence we need in
order for us to determine that something
definitely doesn't work
overall it ended up being a very very
constructive conversation about some
kind of big picture theoretical aspects
of how we interpret research as it comes
out after that we have a brand new
research roundup segment we also answer
a few off-topic questions from our
fireside chat series and that does it
for this episode as always thank you
very much for listening and we hope you
enjoy the show welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host eric Trexler today I am joined by a
very special temporary guest host named
Greg knuckles Greg thank you for joining
me thanks for having me on
quick note a little bit of housekeeping
here before we get into the content with
this episode we are finishing out our
season pretty soon here so today's
episode is going up
June 18th and then we've got one episode
after that on July 2nd and after that we
are in our summer break so we are
planning to come back probably somewhere
in the August September timeframe that's
the plan for now but we won't be gone
the whole time so in the interim period
there we will put out some random audio
content here and there so we won't
totally disappear but we are going to
take a little summer break and then
we'll be back with our regular episodes
after that and in the interest of full
transparency that is mostly to appease
the ghost of Steve Jobs because the way
you know I think like over half of our
listeners are through iTunes
in the way like iTunes podcasts work is
if you're a podcast and you're not put
publishing something at least every six
weeks you stop like Auto downloading
when a new episode comes out so you know
after our last episode we will have to
put something out within at least six
weeks but yeah for the most part we're
gonna be off for a bit and whatever it
is is gonna be sick
I mean it's gonna be some of the
freshest content you've ever seen that's
for sure probably okay so that's that
the bad news is the seasons almost over
we're approaching our summer break but
we have good news as well so for our
good news segment why don't you start us
off Greg yeah so have a bit of good news
on the back of some bad news so the bad
news is metal the power lifting
equipment brand they may you know socks
belt sleeves wraps suits etc their
president I guess owner Otto Finnish guy
he has said some not-so-great stuff
turns out he's been doing like kind of
shitty stuff for years but this may
shock any of our Finnish listeners to
learn not a lot of Finnish news actually
makes it to the States
so apparently you guys have known that
Otto kind of sucks for a while but like
we're just sort of figuring it out so
anyway that's not good
Elite FTS cut ties with metal which
props to Dave TAFE for that they've had
a relationship for a long time so that
that took guts to kind of distance
themselves from the metal line and also
I think most major powerlifting
Federation's in the US have said that
they're no longer going to allow metal
equipment at their meets so that put a
lot of lifters in a tight spot like oh
damn I just bought a new metal singlet
you know three months ago and now I
can't use it in a meet so the power
lifting equipment company SB beast
up and said that they would replace all
metal singlets and deadlift socks that
people have bought in the last year I
believe I know that they extended that
offer to all us APL and us PA members I
I've seen that a few other Federation's
kind of signed on I don't know if SPD
has extended it beyond us APL and us PA
but those are by far the largest
organizations that's where most people
are competing these days so anyway I
thought that was really really cool of
SPD to do because you know I don't know
what metals sales figures are but it
can't be cheap to replace that many
singlets and that many deadlifts socks
it was very much not something they had
to do and I am about as cynical as a
person can be so I I've seen some people
in social media saying like oh like
they're just doing this for good PR and
it's just like no probably not
SPB is already incredibly well known I
think most people have generally
positive associations with the brand and
like even if they do get some good press
out of it they could have probably
benefited more on like a per dollar
basis by I don't know like a [ __ ] ad
campaign so anyway I think that's really
cool of SPD to step up and do that and
that is my good news
awesome so my good news is not related
to the lifting world in any way or at
least not directly
but I found an article on the internet
indicating that there's been a pretty
cool breakthrough in the world of site
restoration and prosthetic eyes so
apparently a group of researchers
created you know what what the lay press
headline calls a bionic eye but
basically it's it functions as an eye
essentially completely completely
man-made by engineers and so a recent
paper in Nature kind of published this
research groups findings like I said
some robot
Engineers put this thing together and
they're estimating that theoretically it
could restore sight to like I think they
said about two hundred and eighty five
million people theoretically so has a
lot of potential to be a huge
breakthrough for visually impaired
people which is really awesome
they're hypothesizing that this could
potentially be available to actually use
it outside of research settings in maybe
as short as five years so pretty cool
breakthrough that should give a lot of
hope to people who are visually impaired
that could be a really cool thing in the
future it'll be interesting to see as
are I'm speaking as somebody with
literally no knowledge here so cut me
some slack but it seems like the the
progress that's being made with tissue
engineering and the progress that's
being made with with robotic engineering
we should see some really really cool
things in the healthcare field over the
next few decades at least that that's
the sense I get i also saw an article
that apparently there's some like brand
new treatment that they're that they're
researching for cauliflower ear so a
very very different application in the
healthcare field but yeah apparently
that they're they're using some kind of
3d bioprinting technology and they say
that they could use this bio printing
technology to kind of restructure the
shape of the outer ear so it's not like
critically important for being able to
hear but you know I grew up in in the
wrestling world you know so I've
wrestled in high school
and I remember back then when you're a
16 year old boy who wrestles it's like
if you don't have a cauliflower ear
you're definitely not cool you're
definitely not tough and nobody takes
you seriously so like every
sixteen-year-old kid in the wrestling
room is dying to develop the just most
mangled cauliflower ear they could
possibly acquire and I would suspect
that now you know 15 20 years later
there are probably people who are like
man I wish my ear didn't look like this
anymore so so hey maybe there's some
good news for those people - I feel like
cauliflower ear is one of those things
that I want to say like profile
the right word but when you see someone
and they have cauliflower ear you know
both consciously and subconsciously like
I just don't want to mess with that
person yes there are very few people out
in the world with cauliflower ear who
didn't earn it you know like they
they've probably they may not be
particularly good at it but they've
probably engaged in some form of combat
with other humans more than you have
yeah and it also indicates they're not
kin they're not super concerned about
being hit yeah they're very comfortable
with that and they're very comfortable
with assuming cosmetic damage in a fight
yeah you know so so whether or not
they're good at fighting you know that
they're willing to assume some risks
here that you might not be willing to
assume it's kind of like trying to
aggressively like merge in traffic if
you see someone who has like a
quarter-million dollar car they're gonna
let you in you know but if someone has
like a 15 year old beater dude you need
to you need to give them a lot of space
because they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
they're missing like two out of three
two out of four hubcaps and they're
their mirrors like taped on with duct
tape like yeah dude they're willing to
take risks on the road correct you know
that but yeah so a couple a couple bio
technological breakthroughs in the
healthcare field that's the good news so
getting back onto Fitness related topics
feats of strength a very popular segment
where we keep people updated on strong
people doing strong person things so
what do we have this week yeah so let's
let's start in the world of strongman
actually so I think everyone by now
knows about Thor's deadlift record 501
kilos but that was actually the first of
kind of a a series of record-breaking
attempts that an organization is
sponsoring and I'm not sure what the
schedule is they might be doing like one
a month one every two week I think it's
like one every two weeks I don't know
all of the details about that but I do
know that like Thor's was the first one
it was the one that was the most hyped
up but but kind of that series is still
ongoing
and the the two that have happened most
recently is Rhiannon Lovelace who is a
64 kilo or approximately 141 pound a
strong woman competitor broke the stone
load world record for her weight class
so it had been a hundred and thirty nine
kilos which is three hundred and six
pounds and she completed one hundred and
forty-one kilos which is three hundred
and ten pounds I think she was planning
on trying 141 151 and 161 and she just
barely missed 151 so I think she had
quite a bit more planned for that day
and you know maybe just the peak didn't
go well I don't really know so it ended
up being a little bit anti-climatic
because her first attempt she just
smashed the world record and she missed
after that and the announcers didn't
the announcers Dinoco is crazy about her
breaking the world record as they did
about Thor because like Thor was just
gonna work up to 501 bought it being
about a boom that's it and for for
Lovelace's attempts like she broke it on
her first attempt and they're like I
whatever no big deal she only broke her
by two kilos she's gonna go up so I I
don't think I don't think it got as much
hype as it maybe deserved but yeah she
she broke that record and she loaded it
over a 44 inch or onto a 44 inch or a
hundred ten centimeter like height so
anyway that's very cool if you've never
done stone loads I don't think I don't
think you know how heavy that is stones
are stones will humble you the the most
the most I've ever loaded I think is
somewhere around what she did and like
that would that would be terrible if I
was a competitive strong man but if if
you compete in strongman you know how
hard stones are if you're a power
lifter or a bodybuilder and you've never
messed with stone loading before it's
it's hard to to put in context just how
impressive a 300 plus pound stone load
is for anyone who's a hundred and forty
pounds and certainly a 140 pound female
competitor also in the world of
strongman Rob Tierney broke the American
record log press with an attempt at four
hundred and seventy five point seven
five pounds are two hundred and fifteen
point eight kilos so that broke the
prior record it's not the world record I
believe oh man I should know this either
Big Z or Eddy Hall has the world record
but Rob here and he broke the American
record which was pretty cool to see for
a couple reasons one is that so he
competes as a super heavyweight the
super heavyweight class and strongman
starts at above 105 kilos and most of
the best strong men in the world are
very big Rob Kearney is not he's not
like Brian Shaw or Thor sighs so it's
it's cool to see that level of success
for a super heavyweight strongman who
who doesn't look like just two
completely different species and
secondly as well
Rob Tierney is very openly gay like his
Instagram handle is world strongest gay
like he very much leans into that so for
him to be able to break that record
during Pride Month pretty cool
moving on to powerlifting our our Julius
Maddox watch segment what do you know
he's still strong and actually I think
now that I think about it I think he's
competing this weekend to try to put up
the first 800-pound bench press I think
I think June 20th is is the meet day am
I crazy or did I hear about him failing
like was 780 or 790 a few weeks ago I
might be crazy I saw people posting
about it because the main takeaway that
he actually might be a human being with
some degree of limitation
I do not remember that maybe it happened
but anyway go on yeah he hit 725 for a
double
that's 329 kilos shouldn't need to tell
you that is a lot of weight and very
impressive next is Russell Orie he hit a
gym squat of seven hundred and fifteen
pounds which is 324 kilos we talked
about Russ leading up to I believe it
was raw Nationals last year and he was
putting up some just absurd numbers in
the gym especially on the squad and at
the time we were saying his his death
looked questionable I think everyone
could tell from his training videos
depth look questionable but depth had
never been a problem in competition for
him before so we just kind of assumed it
would work out on meet day and lo and
behold he shows up at the meet does have
depth issues gets red lighted on depth
his first two attempts has to just you
know hit his opener on his third attempt
just to stay in the meet and didn't put
up the numbers that people were kind of
expecting him to hit but it looks like
his depth problems are sorted out the
7:15 gem squaty hit was to my i
convincing depth he does currently have
the record in that weight class of 691
pounds or three hundred thirteen and a
half kilos that's the 83 kilo class by
the way so yeah it looks like he is
stronger than he's ever been as sorted
out is his depth issues on the squat and
is incredibly strong and finally more
crazy stuff going on in the gym
Ashton Ruska who I've heard rumors that
he's permanently moving up to the 105
kilo class but he has also competed at
the 93 kilo class his current weight is
like 98 kilos or 217 pounds so he's he's
right in between the two but but he
recently hit a gym total of 958 kilos or
212 pounds which
is just bonkers so he competes in USA PL
and IPF and in terms of like stacking
that number up against the tested
records it's ridiculous
so if he competed at 93 again that would
break Jesse norris's all-time record in
that weight class of 914 kilos or 2015
pounds so break it by almost 100 pounds
and the record at 93 is actually higher
than at 105 because Jesse Norris at his
peak was just an absolute monster the
record of 105 is nine hundred and two
and a half kilos or night or 1989 pounds
by Brice Lewis 2112 is a bigger number
than 1989 by by a decent chunk and that
gym total would actually only be like 9
pounds under Caylor woolum untested
record of 21 21 in the hundred kilo or
220 pound weight class so yeah that's
that's absolutely nutty
he's Ashton has clearly been using
quarantine time quite quite productively
one thing I will say about the the
videos of that gym total is he squatted
800 pounds and it's fairly obvious that
his spotters have their hands on the
plates I don't know the degree to which
that helped but I I do think his squad
is probably a bit less than 800 and so
his actual total would be a bit less
than 2112 but you know it's still
probably still probably at least like
7080 pounds better overall than anyone
else in the world in his general weight
classes drug-tested so anyway that's
that's [ __ ] bonkers I can't wait to
see what he does the next time he's back
on the platform alright good stuff ok so
moving on every now and then on the show
we do a segment called stronger by
science article discussion where we
discuss a stronger by science article
that we recently published we kind of
keep the naming conventions really
simple and straightforward so not too
long ago I forget exactly when the
article went up but I wrote an article
about betaine and if you're a longtime
listener of the show you've heard about
betaine before we've talked about it a
few times we even had an interview with
dr. Jason Cole Eva one of our first few
interviews actually where we talked to
him about some of his betaine research
so I wanted to take an opportunity to
talk a little bit about the article but
then transition to some kind of bigger
picture ideas it was really interesting
so you know we'll talk a little bit
about the conclusions of the article but
some of the feedback on the article kind
of kept it kind of touched on some of
these really big ideas these big themes
in terms of how we assess supplement
literature and how we assess a body of
literature that is small but growing so
at when we're watching a body of
scientific literature develop right
before our eyes what do we do with some
of those very early preliminary findings
when there's simply not enough evidence
yet to say that we know conclusively
what a supplement can or can't do so
let's start out with a very brief
summary of what the what the article
concluded basically so there's a little
bit of research looking at betaine on
body composition effects and a little
bit looking at performance effects now
the body composition stuff is what
really interests me and Greg I know
we've talked about this off air quite a
bit but betaine is really fascinating
they give this stuff to pigs all the
time in like the agriculture livestock
industry and what's really fascinating
about that there is research indicating
that it does increase meat yield and in
some cases reduces subcutaneous fat in
pigs what's interesting about that is
that agriculture is a high-stakes
business yeah and the scale of it is
immense so it seems very implausible to
think that there's going to be a lot of
farmers out there who are like you know
what let's throw 40 grand at B
this year and see what happens you know
what I mean I mean when you start
thinking about the scale of some of
these large livestock operations and how
competitive the industry is and just how
much funding there is for livestock
research yeah yeah so it seems the data
from pigs is pretty promising in terms
of body composition effects that doesn't
mean we're gonna say oh cool well works
in pigs I'm sure it works for me right
we want to see that human research as
well but but that is really kind of
where a lot of a lot of the interest
comes from is seeing these positive
effects in in the livestock industry
specifically with pigs now when it comes
to the human research on B Taine's
effects on body composition the body of
literature is actually pretty small
unfortunately they tend to eat a lot of
the studies are kind of short term or
use samples that are not completing any
kind of exercise right so if we just
give betaine to somebody who is you know
not necessarily sedentary but just
somebody who doesn't exercise and
doesn't train based on the research
there would really be no reason to
suspect any notable changes there not
really any notable changes when it comes
to fat loss or muscle gain or anything
like that you you give betaine to
someone who's not training it doesn't
seem to do much at all for body
composition there's a couple studies
saying oh maybe a slight reduction in
body fat but it's it's not super
convincing at this time however there
are a couple studies showing some pretty
promising effects for body composition
in humans the thing that's interesting
is that the studies with the most
promising effects tend to be you know
decent in terms of their duration we're
talking six or eight weeks which is much
better than a one or two week study and
they typically include a pretty robust
stimulus for muscle growth so we've had
Jason Khalifa on the show he ran a
couple studies that showed yeah he ran a
couple studies that showed pretty decent
effects on body composition fat loss and
muscle gain metrics and what was
interesting about his studies were that
he had a really nice training stimulus
involved you know it was a
solid training program created to induce
hypertrophy so these kinds of studies
that we have for body composition like I
said very small body of literature and
you know we're talking about six or
eight week studies here so based on the
number of studies based on the duration
of the studies there's really not enough
here to form a definitive conclusion and
say oh yeah if you add betaine into the
mix you are going to grow more muscle or
lose more fat over the course of a
training program but what's interesting
is the studies that are most relevant to
most of our listeners that actually have
that training component do seem to have
the most promising effects so with body
composition I think it would be
premature to conclude yes this is
definitely going to work you know put it
on that tier of supplements with
creatine where you know you feel really
really good about spending that money I
think it's promising though and so the
way I approach betaine recommendations
for body composition purposes in the
article is there's enough there to have
some curiosity and to have maybe a
little bit of optimism so if you're
approaching it as if you're kind of
testing the waters and experimenting I
think that there's at least enough
positive evidence there to make you feel
good about engaging in the experiment
right
whereas if we're talking about body
composition and it's something like
branched-chain amino acids I'd be like
that experiments been done it's not
going to be exciting right betaine
because of because there's a small
amount of data but there is some promise
there I feel comfortable saying yeah you
could justify experimenting with it can
I ask you a question that doubles as a
Segway sure have you considered that
maybe you're just a [ __ ] sheep and
betaine does nothing and all of the
research findings that that suggests
that betaine might do anything are
purely due to massive and extreme
financial conflicts of interest yeah
yeah I could address that so yeah I will
so after this article came out there's
kind of a resurgence of an infographic
getting shared around
and the graphic basically indicates that
when it comes to kind of a mixture of
performance and body comp studies that
all the studies showing a positive
effect of betaine have these like really
egregious conflicts of interest and all
the studies that show no benefit of
betaine are completely absent of
conflicts of interest and so it creates
this kind of perfect dichotomy where the
general idea is if there is a conflict
of interest you will find a positive
outcome if there isn't a conflict of
interest you definitely won't that's a
that's a very tidy narrative it's it is
up until the point that you test it and
determine if that's true
yeah if that turned out to be the case
that would be a very tidy narrative yeah
and so it it's just not it's just not
really the case so you know here's one
thing you could say you could say that
the studies with the most promising
outcomes do happen to have conflicts of
interest and that's fair that that would
be accurate but but that narrative that
it's this kind of perfect one-to-one
correlation not factually accurate and
what's what's actually interesting is
that I would argue that the conflicts of
interest that matter the most are
present in some of the studies reporting
virtually no benefit at all are you
telling me that not all conflicts of
interest are created equal that's
exactly what I'm telling you so I think
that one of the things that's humorous
is people assume like I think people are
viewing this from like the big pharma
kind of perspective like yeah if you
have some pharmaceutical company that's
just feeding you study money for these
like enormous clinical trials over the
course of several years
yeah that that's that's quite a cash cow
you know that you're going back to you
you wouldn't want that well to dry up
you know so like you you could see that
there might be some conflict there that
that would have to be it's not a deal
breaker but it has to be carefully
managed and you'd want to take a close
look at that and make sure everything's
on the up-and-up yeah the thing is the
conflicts of interest with getting a
supplement trial funded it's like
it's usually like we will send you like
six bottles of betaine and like 500
bucks you know what I mean so it's it's
not exactly the type of thing that you
sell your soul for or not always the 500
bucks and not always the yeah it's it's
very it's very often like we'll send you
some bottles of the supplement we'll
send you some bottles of the placebo and
then you invest six months of your life
to run this study exactly and by the way
the 500 bucks is not for the the per the
person running the study like hey for
your time here's 500 bucks the 500 bucks
is either going to buy you know 500
bucks worth of plates for the for the
lab or it's going to be distributed so
you can actually pay the participants in
the study so that you can actually
recruit people cuz like you're asking
them to come to your lab for eight weeks
three days a week plus pre and
post-testing so like it's nice if you
can say oh hey can we get like a
thousand dollars of funding so that we
can pay all of our subjects pennies on
the dollar for their time you know
because I mean it's a lot of times with
these studies you're paying subjects
like 40 bucks and they're coming to the
lab for like 12 total hours or something
like and that that's for a non training
study for a training study they're
coming all the time what I will say
though is I remember being in college I
would have done a lot of [ __ ] for 40
bucks no I mean yeah the market sets the
price and that's the price these days it
seems but in any case you know some of
the studies that are reporting null
findings when it comes to I don't know
how many of them looked at perform but
there were some with performance but
definitely some with body composition as
well you know you look at what are the
potential conflicts there I know for a
couple of the papers reporting null
findings you know the lead author had
filed patents related to betaine
supplementation I mean that's a big like
if you're filing a patent like you know
how much money and time goes into filing
a patent like that's not from what I
understand not a fun easy or inexpensive
process so if you're filing patents
related to betaine you're hoping it
works
yeah and again that that doesn't mean
you can't study it because we do have in
like this where there are people
transparent on the up-and-up doing
honest work who say it'd be really great
for me if betaine worked but it didn't
you know there are also a number of
papers reporting null findings where
some of the authors on the author list
of the paper are full-time employees of
the company that sells the betaine and
provided it for the study and so like
the thing that kills me is that you know
people are worried about this conflict
of interest because some professor at a
university got three bottles of betaine
and you know $600 it's like dude one of
these authors if this betaine company
folds they got a move I think they got
to put their kids in a different school
and sell their house like that's kind of
a big deal you know so like if there's
authors on the paper who have that much
of their life connected to betaine to me
that's a bigger conflict of interest
than who provided the betaine correct
you know what I mean so so yeah that
there it's not to say that that graphic
is completely without merit because like
I said if you were to say well I'm not
going to be convinced about betaine it
until I see a study that is that has
really positive findings and is not
funded by a company with conflicts of
interest it would be very fair to say
it's hard to find a really positive
finding that was privately funded or you
know completely absent of conflicts of
interest so that's a fair point you can
make okay so I don't want to like pile
on and say that there's that there's no
merit to that line of conversation but
there are people kind of sharing an
image indicating that the the
relationship so a little bit more
insidious and a little bit more perfect
than it than it really is right yeah
like there there are several null
findings where conflicts of interests
were present including very large
conflicts of interest definitely yeah
yeah so
another thing that I found kind of funny
is in a discussion about that I saw
somebody bringing up hmb Oh God because
they're like oh I see a graphic here
that's leading me to believe there's
conflicts of interest I'm going to draw
a parallel to the hmb research and it's
like dude the reason people were upset
the reason that HMV stuff got
controversial wasn't because the study
was funded by somebody it was because
the results were out of this world you
know what I mean like dude so if you're
talking about like if you look at the
magnitude of these positive findings and
the betaine studies they're not that big
I mean so it's a complete apples and
oranges comparison there so that that
comparison to me is completely
unjustifiable completely unwarranted
like come on HM be like but yeah I mean
you wrote an article about some of the
hmb research for stronger by science
where I was like dude look at the
results look at what we would expect
from steroids
like these findings are just
astronomically out of left field yeah it
was absolutely ridiculous
yeah so so okay that's that part getting
back on on track here so with the body
composition stuff we've got some studies
in the six to eight week time frame with
a good resistance training stimulus on
top of it that give us enough evidence
to feel intrigued but not enough to say
oh yeah this is a sure thing safe bet if
you're not on detain you're an idiot
like we're not even close to that yet
but there's enough to at least justify
it when it comes to performance there's
kind of some mixed inconsistent findings
there have been a few instances where
performance improvements have been noted
but there have been several instances
where they've looked at a number of
different performance outcomes and found
nothing significant to report in terms
of benefits one of the very notable
things about that body of literature if
you want to interpret it very charitably
is most of the studies are one or two
weeks long that's short and I think with
betaine I'm more interested in some of
the long-term effects and when it comes
to a theoretical performance
Vantage from betaine I'm interested in
seeing if it really does enhance
hypertrophy over time does it help with
our long-term strength increases looking
at the theoretical mechanisms by which
betaine could possibly affect
performance I'm not that optimistic
about a super short-term benefit I'm
more interested in performance benefits
that might be secondary to the
hypertrophy benefits and so I think if
you like I said if you want if you want
to have a very uncharitable assessment
of the literature you'd say it seems
like a lot of times it doesn't work and
you can just discard it but I think a
more charitable approach would be you
know these one to two week time frames
and they all pretty much use the same
dose by the way they're pretty much all
looking at one or two weeks of
supplementation with 2.5 grams a day so
if we're looking at which I'll note is
is noteworthy because again humans are
not pigs but the the livestock
literature tends to use dosages that are
approximately twice what like when
scaling for body mass or approximately
double what's used in humans so you know
it very well could be like a dose
dependency thing where like the two and
a half grams per day used in the
research may do a little something for
you but it doesn't provide super
reliable effects whereas maybe like five
or six grams per day would but that just
hasn't been tested in humans yet yeah
and so I think I think it would be
interesting to see some more betaine
literature using longer interventions
which I mean that's easy to say for me
because I don't have to run it we're
funded but longer interventions I think
are more likely to review if there is a
benefit to be revealed
I think longer interventions closer to
the 16 20 24 week time frame are
probably more likely to reveal some of
those theoretical strength benefits and
like I said that when you only have a
single dose being observed most the time
and most of the studies are 1 to 2 weeks
long I just can't help but wonder like
if we decided to
you know let's say our understanding of
creatine was limited when we first
started looking at the applied effects
and we didn't understand that the
process of loading if we just ran a
handful of studies and said okay we're
gonna give five grams a day for two
weeks and see if it affects strength
most of those studies probably wouldn't
find much you know what I mean I mean
maybe you're increasing muscle creatine
enough with that dosing strategy over
two weeks maybe but but I mean we
wouldn't really fully appreciate
creatine's effects if we didn't know oh
it actually takes a loading phase and we
need to make sure we reach the
saturation level and we need to give it
enough time to actually make that
saturation occur you know so I mean or
even just imagine protein
supplementation like hey we're gonna
give people one scoop of protein powder
per day for a week or two lo and behold
doesn't do [ __ ] you know what I'm right
yeah and so I just want to be very
transparent you know someone listening
to this might say well Eric you seem to
be very charitable with your with how
you're interpreting the betaine
literature and I think that's very fair
like what I'm interested in is we see a
lot of supplements come along and most
of them just right out of the gate you
look at the premise and you're like it
just doesn't make sense like there are
no mechanisms here that I find to be
compelling there's no animal eat there's
not a decent amount of animal research
that would give me a reason to have a
lot of hope here so a lot of these
supplements you know right right off the
bat you're like I just don't see a lot
of potential here with betaine I think
it's one of those interesting scenarios
where you can see the potential you
don't know if it'll pan out yet but what
what I find really interesting and this
kind of connects to the bigger picture
thing which is kind of what do we do
with a body of literature that's just
developing and kind of what is our
starting point when we're evaluating
whether or not a supplement or any any
training or nutrition intervention
what's our starting point for
determining whether or not something is
worth it and I think it's really
interesting a lot of people seem to have
a perspective where they are going to
assume that that a potent let's just say
supplement to keep it as a very relevant
example some random supplement comes
along
and they are going to assume the
position I absolutely will not in
entertain the idea that this could work
until I am absolutely conclusively
proven otherwise
you know so that that's an okay stance
to have and if you look at kind of the
theoretical underpinnings of null
hypothesis testing
you could argue maybe that's where
you're supposed to start right I mean
that's the whole point with any
statistical test with the kind of
frequentist approach is I'm going to
assume the null hypothesis which is you
know this thing ain't going to work
there's no effect and only when there's
enough evidence to reject that will I
start to say okay maybe there's
something there and so I think a lot of
people view supplementation that way and
that's a totally fine way to do it but
the that's not the only way to do it and
it's not necessarily always the best way
to do it so just to give an example if
you were to look at the the creatine
literature for example athletes were
using it in the 80s it didn't really
start to break into the research
literature until the early 90s and if
you were gonna apply that standard of
you know only once I'm very conclusively
proven from a decent body of literature
and you know theoretically a
meta-analysis kind of summarizing it
only then will I say okay it's worth a
shot
that's okay but you probably spent close
to 15 years watching all your friends
benefit from creatine before you gave it
a shot you know it probably wouldn't
have been until about 2001 or 2003 that
you would have said okay there's
something to this creatine thing I think
I think I might give it a shot and
that's okay like if your biggest
interest is in never swinging and
missing that's a completely fine stance
to have and you're never going to look
back and say man 15 years totally wasted
because I didn't have a supplement yeah
and it it gets more extreme than
creatine as well one of the things we we
talked about after the betaine article
went up and as we were outlining this
episode is like you know when we think
supplements we think stuff like protein
creatine caffeine etc but
people kind of forget how the the
steroid literature went so that's like a
pretty extreme example of of a lot of
the stuff we've been talking about
actually so like was the dosing
appropriate yadda yadda yadda and like
you know did you wait long enough to see
the literature develop so if you go and
I think this is one of the things people
don't think about mostly because you
know at this point everyone knows that
steroids work and most of the like
steroid trials that people will cite
will be from the 90s or later but if you
go back and look at the early research
on anabolic steroids that started in
like the 70s and into the 80s the
research consensus for a hot minute was
that steroids didn't really do anything
and the reason for that is like a
typical study would be like hey we're
gonna give people ten milligrams of D
ball once a week and see if that does
anything and like lo and behold doesn't
really do anything or at least like
doesn't reliably have a particularly
large effect and so like you can you can
go and read like narrative reviews from
researchers in the late 80s early 90s
that say look these athletes like there
might be some risks from using steroids
and around that time like they were
starting to get banned in sports like
they're risking bands they're risking
their careers one we don't even know
that steroid should be banned in sports
because we don't really think they do
anything but to these athletes seem to
be behaving very irrationally and taking
on a lot of risk without meaningful
benefit and then the scene comes out in
96 and it's like you [ __ ] are
given people ten milligrams of D ball
once a week I'm gonna start giving
people 600 milligrams of test every week
and let's see if that does something and
lo and behold if [ __ ] does something
like researchers were like oh [ __ ] these
steroids that athletes have been doing
maybe they knew what they were talking
about
yeah that's that's a body of literature
where you could have watched it
developed for 20 years like over 20
years and been like well does it do
something maybe but we're not sure yeah
it was I I think that's not quite as
good of an example as creatine cuz like
people were using appropriate doses of
creatine both kind of in the real world
and in the research and it just took a
while for the body of literature to
develop but yeah with with steroid
literature like just the studies
themselves were completely inadequate
for over two decades and it led people
to be skeptical about whether anabolic
steroids actually had a positive effect
and you know I'm not recommending
everyone go out there and do gear but
until until a lot later than I think a
lot of people realize steroids were
completely allowed in sports and boy
would you have been an idiot as like an
Olympic coach in the 70s when everyone
was doing steroids and they were
completely allowed to say well the
research that's out there isn't all that
positive so my athletes are just gonna
you know train hard and eat clean like
that uh that probably would have cost
your athletes quite a few medals
probably so and just to be super clear I
know we're using some metaphors here
betaine is not steroids
oh yeah and not not trying to make that
impe action at all I just I want to be
very clear some people took some extreme
liberties with misinterpreting the
betaine article anyway betaine not only
is it not steroids betaine is not the
next creatine
I already feel comfortable enough to say
that the question is is it gonna be once
the body of literature develops the way
I put in the article is can it be one of
those second-tier supplements you know
could it be something that we view like
like a beta alanine or a citrulline
malate you know something on that tier
of supplements where you're like well it
it ain't creatine but maybe it does have
a reliable or genic benefit if it's
dosed for the right
you know if it's dosed correctly and
taken for a long enough time to actually
promote hypertrophy you know so that's
that's kind of where I see it in terms
of its potential upside but you know
kind of the the better or I guess the
overarching point that you're hinting
out there is when do we call it you know
as a body of literature is developing
when do we officially say that's it
this is a waste just stop studying it
it's a waste of time right can you
imagine if we did those those first five
or ten years of steroid research and
said dude we already have the studies it
doesn't do anything just give up on it
you know that's kind of the sense I got
from some of the feedback on the beat an
article it's like oh my god be tan again
let it go man there's like six studies
saying it didn't work and I'm like dude
if you apply that logic to the
literature if we look at caffeine and
its effects on maximal strength the
first several studies coming out were
pretty unimpressive but as the body of
literature developed we start to say oh
okay that it looks like we've got an
effect size here that's somewhere
between trivial and small right so
somewhere in that point 15.2 range
but I think a lot of people now are
warming up to the idea that caffeine can
have a positive impact on maximal
strength and there are some meta
analyses now that would indicate that
you know another interesting story is
kind of kind of the inverse of that if
we look at how the citrulline malate
literature developed the first few
studies came out and we're talking about
effect sizes that are up in the 0.3 to
0.5 range and we're like man this
citrulline malate especially for
something like reps to fatigue is like
it's pretty up there in terms of effect
size and so for the first few years of
that body of literature it was you know
kind of bigger effect sizes and then
there were a series of studies came that
came out that kind of brought us back
down to earth a little bit and there
were a few studies in a row that had
some non significant findings which with
much smaller effect sizes and so one of
the ways I like to view a developing
body of literature is I like to view it
like a funnel plot you know what I mean
so a funnel plot in a meta-analysis
we've got the the kind of average effect
size we would expect but as studies kind
of get smaller or have more variability
we expect them to deviate from that
average so if as a supplements true
effect size is point two we expect we're
gonna see some small studies that get
like a a negative point two and maybe a
point six for the effect size we expect
some degree of spread when it comes to
these small you know
quickly-put-together trials and so when
I'm looking at a body of literature
developed you know we look at something
like like caffeine and we see that
there's these small effect sizes but
what we didn't know at the time was
they're clustering around point two or
something like that so there is an
effect here it's just a bunch of small
effect sizes that when they when they
get pooled together they're going to
show us that there is a trivial to small
effect here but we can't see what
they're clustering around until we let
that body of literature develop when you
look at citrulline malate what happened
was the right side of the funnel plot
filled in first chronologically so we
saw all these kind of
larger-than-average effects in hindsight
at the time we didn't know they were
larger than average we just thought
those were the average but then we
started sending time they were the
average well correct yeah and then we
start to see some of the other studies
fill in the left side of that funnel
plot some of the a little bit below
average results and they're clustering
around a number that's greater than zero
but we initially kind of over estimated
the effect size of citrulline malate I
think I still think it's useful don't
get me wrong but but for a while there
we were overestimating its effect size
and so I think what's interesting about
anytime you're looking at a developing
body of supplement literature if your
biggest concern is that you never ever
want to give it a shot and miss and say
wow I wasted 20 bucks on that supplement
of course you can wait it out and you're
never going to regret that in a big way
you're never gonna be like ah damn that
supplement just changed everybody's
lives except for mine because I missed
out supplements don't have that big of
an effect but the way I view supplement
literature is
it's developing I'm waiting to see how
that funnel plots gonna fill in and if
it's clustering around zero or we're
seeing a bunch of super small or even
negative effect sizes exclusively that
I'm like okay well I don't see any
reason to to really entertain that idea
yet that doesn't mean they should just
shut down the body of research
necessarily but I want to let that
develop and see what happens and for me
the way I'm looking at a supplement is
not I need you to absolutely
conclusively prove to me that this is
going to change my life but rather if
there's no risk of side effects you know
you know if we already know that it's
safe well tolerated no side effects and
it can't hurt my performance and we're
starting to see a couple a couple
positive findings trickling out and some
that are not negative but they're kind
of closer to zero maybe I will entertain
the idea you know it's kind of a like I
said testing the waters treating it kind
of like like an experiment don't give it
a shot and see if I like it and if not
you know then I had you know no side
effects it didn't hurt my performance it
just didn't help and I wasted 20 bucks
yeah so you know I I would say honestly
you should never buy a supplement with
money that you're not comfortable
wasting I mean we're talking about small
effect sizes here right yeah so so yeah
that that's kind of my viewpoint is
there's two different schools of thought
when it comes to these developing bodies
of of literature with a supplement and I
think it's important to kind of think
about where you are in terms of those
schools of thought so if someone were to
tell me Eric the betaine evidence to me
is not compelling because I haven't been
conclusively proven that this is gonna
going to benefit me for sure I would
totally agree with that I would say
there's absolutely not enough proof to
tell you for sure that that betaine is
you know a definite thing it's a safe
that take it you're going to improve
your performance or you're gonna have
you know notable hypertrophy but but I
also on the flip side of that I don't
think there's nearly enough to say
betaine absolute waste I'm sure of it
we shouldn't even do research because
there's no way that could possibly be
beneficial if you take the approach that
or if you have the viewpoint that that's
where the research is I don't see where
you're getting that from
III think right now it's inconclusive
there's some glimmers of hope and really
what it comes down to is your appetite
for experimentation and your appetite
for taking that risk and when it comes
to something like betaine if we had no
idea what the suck what the health and
safety profile was then I'd probably say
leave it but but for something like
betaine it seems to be very safe very
well tolerated there's some evidence
that if you're taking it with resistant
resistance training it might have some
positive effects the effects on body
composition are more promising than the
effects on performance but again that's
within the context of mostly pretty
short trials so just I thought that was
a useful conversation to have because I
think a lot of people miss those
historical contexts of the things that
we know work in hindsight what did it
look like to watch that body of
literature actually develop in real time
and so when it comes to betaine we have
the opportunity to watch that develop in
real time and the question is what do we
how do we continue to update our
assessment as it develops you know and
so that's kind of the the background for
how I frame the conclusions in the
betaine article and just to make a
really concise summary statement 2.5
grams a day seems to be safe and well
tolerated there's no evidence that would
hurt performance the performance data is
not particularly impressive there are
some bright spots or some little
glimmers of hope when it comes to body
composition both with fat loss and
muscle gain and so for those reasons it
you know if you are comfortable testing
the waters making it into a little bit
of an experiment and saying maybe I'll
give betaine a shot I think it's at
least justifiable to say that that's an
experiment worth undertaking I agree I
think it's a I think it's also worth
just kind of considering this from like
a philosophy of science perspective
because you you mentioned kind of
assumptions baked into null hypothesis
significance testing and how you know
you're you you're supposed to assume
that something doesn't do anything and
you're you're waiting for fairly
convincing evidence that it might do
something I think it's worth considering
kind of where that idea came from and
also where the field of exercise science
gets a lot of it's both like research
and statistical conventions from so a
lot of our research conventions come
from like biomedical and pharmaceutical
research like I mean a supplement study
is kind of just like a shitty clinical
trial for a drug and that's that's where
a lot of those conventions came from and
then a lot of the statistical
conventions used across a lot of the
sciences came from people who primarily
operated in psychology and I think those
two things are worth keeping in mind for
a couple reasons
one is that as far as weighting the
risks of a false positive versus a false
negative goes a lot of that comes from
biomedical research and the thing with
that is like the the cost of a false
positive is pretty enormous when it
comes to pharmaceutical and biomedical
research one because like if you say a
drug is good and effective when it turns
out to not be you know you very well
could be one risking a lot of people's
health and lives because there very well
could be another drug out there that's
more effective that you're now giving a
less effective drug to because of a
false positive and also like the the
acute risks can be larger as well
because most most pharmaceuticals have
you know they have risks and side
effects that are greater than the risk
of say creatine so there's and another
thing as well is like if there's quite a
few false positive there's several false
positives for a particular treatment
approach or a particular drug and people
who are you know making million dollar
grants start seeing this and they're
like oh [ __ ] this seems promising let's
pump millions of dollars into
studying this thing to develop this
treatment that then you know it's kind
of a zero-sum game those are millions of
dollars that aren't going towards
looking for other new drugs or
treatments or continuing to study
something else that seems promising and
so that could set a field back because
you're you're chasing a rabbit hole with
finite research funds and so there's a
huge huge costs for false positives in
kind of the fields that exercise science
grew out of
and so there's reasonably high criteria
for saying like okay this is promising
enough to continue moving forward
whereas I would say the the risks of
false positives versus false negatives
are like the costs of false positives
versus false negatives are are different
when it comes to exercise science
generally and like supplement studies as
well because like dude if you're
studying if you're studying a new
periodization idea and like maybe this
idea is like slightly better than
another one but maybe it's not quite
statistically significant maybe it's a
p-value of 0.05
dude if you go with option B over option
a who gives a [ __ ]
you know like like the actual risks to
the athlete probably aren't all that
different and like the cost of being
wrong is just like oh well could have
put fifteen pounds on my squat this
training cycle and instead I put ten you
know like yeah it's just not that big of
a deal and the same thing with
supplement research like there aren't
that many supplements that people are
studying that don't seem to be pretty
safe and so like ultimately if you're
maybe a little bit too excited about a
particular supplement that on down the
line it turns out to not be very
effective like yeah you're out some
money and that's not great but it's you
know it's not the same thing as like
like prescribing thalidomide to a bunch
of pregnant women and then having mass
birth defects you know right and you
know just to be clear like I don't want
to trivialize how much it stings when
when some you know you buy into the good
marketing from the supplement company
you buy a few tubs of it and then you
look back in hindsight you're like
dammit
they got me you know I get it and I was
a full-time student from 2009 to 2010
year period we're like dude I just
didn't supplement much at all because I
was like dude I'm not gonna steal from
my grocery fund to buy some special
powder so like just to kind of put this
in practical terms these are real things
like I have had clients come up to me
and ask me Eric as someone interested in
strength and hypertrophy do you think I
should take creatine and I'd say it
sounds like a damn good idea to me and
they come up to me and say Eric do you
think I should take branched-chain amino
acids to support my hypertrophy goals on
a high protein diet and I'd say I don't
think that's gonna be beneficial someone
very much in real life came up to me a
month or two ago and said should I take
betaine I'd say well it could help if
you don't take it we're not gonna miss
anything but if you're interested and
you're enthusiastic about it it appears
to be safe there's some evidence that it
might help it's really up to you you
know so that's where I'm at with it I
and and that's kind of where the article
settles and so I was very surprised some
people were absolutely flabbergasted by
what they perceived as a unequivocal
endorsement for betaine from my article
like it just seems I'm just not ready to
completely throw it away yet that that's
pretty much where I'm at I'm throwing
branched-chain amino acids away they're
dead they're dead to me they're out the
door
creatine it's great betaine it's in the
middle and we have to be able to be kind
of comfortable with that you know for
now until we learn more but but yeah so
that is the rundown of the article
sounds good so we we have actually had
two more recent articles published on
the site as well
Vaden and they didn't court the same
degree of discussion or controversy but
just want to make a little plug here so
you know they are out there if you
primarily listen to the podcast but
don't check the site that often so we we
recently republished a
video that that initially appeared in
mass from Mike Soros about returning to
training after a layoff
that includes a spreadsheet that that
kind of lays out how a how an example
program might look for easing back into
training so we we published that a
couple weeks ago free resource on the
site if you would like to check it out
and we also recently published an
article from our in-house ptj senior and
it covers kind of the risks that you
might want to be aware of when it comes
to maybe getting back into training too
hard too fast after a layoff I'm I'm
concerned that physical therapists might
be about to have a huge spike in
business as Jim start opening back up
you know and people are very D trained
and they start trying to train exactly
like they were training before so so
that article from Jason covers some of
the the risks associated with that and
just things to be aware of reiterates a
lot of the points from Mike's video but
that is another good article to check
out and I'll just note if if you've
already got back into the gym and hit
things a little too hard
wound up with some sort of injury or
that that occurs to you within the next
couple of weeks or months
Jason on staff he's great
if you want to talk to a physical
therapist about some sort of injury pain
or limitation that's not just going to
tell you like oh you're back sore guess
you should never squat again Jason would
be a good person to talk to he is a
lifter we're buddies with him like he
understands how strength athletes and
people obsessed with iron feel about all
of this stuff so you know he'll he'll be
able to give you advice and guide you
through the the rehab and return to
training process after pains injuries
limitations better than maybe a physical
therapist who isn't as well associated
with iron sports and that's huge I mean
I'm probably preaching to the choir here
but it is crazy how important it is to
find a solid physical therapist who
understands how much lifting means to
you and kind of has a background related
to lifting a lot of absolutely
incredible physical therapists out there
but I remember one time I had a lifting
related injury and I went in I said hey
so I've been treating my body like a
rental for like 15 years 10 years 15
years and my hip hurts because I lift a
lot and I'm in kind of an idiot and they
explored every possible reason for that
pain accept anything hip related I was
like yeah but it's like I'm just telling
you guys like a I squat low bar ask to
grass no one else in the world does it's
stupid I'm just it's got torque on top
of torque on this hip and I think the
hips in bad shape and they're like well
it could be anything else it's like I
just didn't get help with it you know
and so it really is nice when you can go
to someone say hey I know that you know
lifting you know how much this means to
me let's be pragmatic about finding a
solution you know okay you want to move
on to research round up I think we
should okay cool so research round up
this is a segment where we give some not
super in-depth discussion of recent
research but we kind of give you the
highlights of papers that have come out
recently now if you want more of this
content like I said we've got we've got
our summer break coming up so if you
want to continue getting some good
research roundup content during our
podcast break you can always go to
stronger by science com get on the email
list and we email out additional
research roundup content in the written
form so we'll come straight to your
email inbox so one of the studies I saw
recently was about vitamin C and
recovery this was a meta-analysis so
vitamin C it's a well known antioxidant
we've talked about antioxidants on the
show quite a bit in the past very common
thought here is that high-dose vitamin C
supplementation will reduce oxidative
stress and inflammation caused by
training
and theoretically this would improve
recovery and performance and so the idea
is if you're training like crazy and
you're causing all this oxidative stress
and inflammation if you could take this
vitamin C it would attenuate some of
that mitigate some of that so you could
get back into the gym earlier and train
harder because of those theoretical
recovery benefits so recent
meta-analysis put this theory to the
test they looked at the effect of
vitamin C supplementation on lipid
peroxidation and that's indicative of
oxidative stress they also looked at
interleukin 6 or il six which is a
marker of inflammation they looked at
creatine kinase they looked at
c-reactive protein cortisol they also
looked at soreness and strength recovery
after some pretty intense exercise bouts
so what they found here cutting right to
the results
there was a small reduction in lipid
peroxidation and il-6
in response to vitamin C supplementation
and again this is a meta-analysis so
they looked at several studies that that
all looked at those particular outcomes
what's interesting though so starting
out you think okay well that supports
the theory right we're gonna reduce
oxidative stress inflammation that's
going to improve all these different
aspects of recovery what's really
interesting is that the other outcomes
were not significantly impacted in a
meaningful way and so what we saw there
is that there were these mock these
modest reductions in markers of
oxidative stress and inflammation
however that didn't actually translate
over into the things we really care
about as a lifter right so if you ask
them are you more sore or less sore the
soreness was not impacted in a
meaningful way same thing when it comes
to the actual recovery of strength
performance after those those intense
exercise sessions so you know this is
something that came up in the
antioxidant article that I wrote a few
months ago for stronger by science and
you know we looked a little bit at some
of the research you know there is some
research indicating that really high
dose vitamin C could theoretically blunt
hypertrophy to a small degree that
evidence is inconsistent and the effect
doesn't seem to be huge so a lot of
people are out there worried about if I
have too much vitamin C in my diet is it
going to
my games the answer is probably not and
if it does have an effect it's going to
be pretty small but but the research
there is pretty mixed um but one of the
things I brought up in the article is a
good question would be why you why you
doing this high high dose vitamin C
supplementation in the first place
because what we see looking at the
literature and this meta-analysis kind
of supports this contention is that
while it might not necessarily kill your
gains there just doesn't seem to be much
of a good reason to do it this perceived
benefit this idea that it's gonna you
know completely change your your ability
to adapt to training and get you back in
the gym quicker and stronger it just
doesn't seem to pan out in the studies
that actually directly assess that
question so I'm still not convinced that
you need to worry that if your vitamin C
increases above a certain threshold from
food sources that that's going to have
any bearing on your ability to grow in
response to training however I just
don't see a really compelling reason for
a healthy individual to be using this
high-dose vitamin C as a recovery aid if
you're interested in using some kind of
some kind of antioxidant based
supplement for recovery there's much
better evidence for things like tart
cherry juice you know there are some
kind of polyphenol based like
pomegranate blends and watermelon juice
blends that that have a bunch of other
active phytonutrients in them that seem
to have better effects on actual
recovery and even like turmeric or yes
sir
Kirk humans curcumin OIG's yeah yeah
there are a lot of you know a lot more
of these kind of phytonutrient pact
supplement blends that are based on like
I said you know turmeric curcumin
pomegranate watermelon tart cherry and
they just seem to perform better in
terms of the actual tangible recovery
parameters we care about soreness and
are you back to full strength quicker so
if you want to go that direction and
you're interested in some kind of
antioxidant supplementation that might
relate to enhance blood flow enhanced
recovery something like that I would
encourage you to check out that stronger
by science article stronger by science
comm slash antioxidants I
going to some of the details and one of
the most important things is some that
came up in the betaine article as well
whenever possible I try to recommend
dietary swaps that would achieve the
same effect rather than rather than you
know buying a new supplement and going
out of your way and spending a bunch of
money so when it comes to betaine I
think there are ways to get some more
betaine into your diet without
necessarily buying a supplement it takes
a little bit of effort yeah there are
some specific foods that are pretty high
in betaine but the same thing goes with
these different antioxidant based
approaches to recovery you know there
are some foods that that just deliver a
ton of antioxidants with a variety of
other phytonutrients just naturally
present in the food and so if you're
interested in seeing what some of those
foods are you can go to stronger by
science comm slash antioxidants and
check those out another study that came
out recently that I wanted to briefly
highlight another meta-analysis I'm kind
of I'm it's pretty transparent I'm on a
meta-analysis kick lately I just really
like him I find them interesting I like
to get into the methods a little bit
with them but in any case there's a
recent meta-analysis on bicarbonate
sodium bicarbonate and so that this has
been a popular supplement for for
decades now the idea is that you know
you supplement with bicarbonate the
bicarbonate buffer buffering system
plays an important role in regulating
blood pH and dealing with the build-up
of all those hydrogen ions that
accumulate during really intense
exercise so especially something like
Sprint work high repetition resistance
training those things that cause a big
buildup of hydrogen ions that's where we
would expect sodium bicarbonate to to
really shine so this meta-analysis
looked at 13 studies that included some
kind of muscular endurance outcome they
also looked at strength outcomes as well
and they found 11 studies looking at
that and they did some interesting
subgroup analyses too that I'll talk
about but the overall effect here so it
did have a positive effect sodium
bicarbonate supplementation did have a
positive effect on muscular endurance
the effect size was point
seven they looked at small muscle groups
versus large muscle groups and it didn't
really seem to be much of a difference
they weren't completely identical but it
was pretty similar maybe slightly in
favor of large muscle groups but from a
statistical perspective they look quite
similar sodium bicarbonate did not have
a meaningful effect or a statistically
significant effect on muscular strength
and that didn't matter whether whether
muscular strength was measured in the
rested state or in the fatigued state I
think intuitively they were probably
expecting resting it won't do much but
maybe in the fatigue State there's
something there that that would be my
assumption but it just didn't pan out
that way for strength then the numbers
just weren't very impressive so nothing
really
earth-shattering here nothing super
surprising I mean usually that's the way
it goes with meta analyses when a
meta-analysis when the results
absolutely blindside you it's usually
not a good sign it usually me it usually
means that you either did not know that
literature the way you thought you did
or potentially there was a mistake made
in the analysis I know it seems like a
far-fetched idea but it happens
sometimes Greg but but this was a very
well-done meta-analysis and very much
you know the results were quite
intuitive I think for a long time people
have known sodium bicarbonate it's kind
of what I consider one of those
second-tier supplements right so it's
not creatine in terms of the magnitude
of effect or the reliability or the
consistency of the effect has a slightly
more narrow subset of exercise tasks
that it's likely to to benefit you know
one of the magic things about creatine
that that's incredible is the number of
different outcomes it positively affects
so sodium bicarbonate is much more
limited as a supplement but if you're
doing a lot of really intense work
especially like Sprint work
middle-distance work or very high
repetition lifting there is evidence
suggesting that sodium bicarbonate could
be ineffective supplementation strategy
now one thing I will note if you're
thinking about experimenting with sodium
bicarbonate supplementation make sure
that it actually makes sense for the
type of training that you do
you know if you're just doing a bunch of
low repetition work with plenty of rest
between sets it's probably probably not
the right supplement for you but you
also want to keep a close eye on your
dosing strategy so there was a recent
paper that looked at a pretty creative
dosing strategy for sodium bicarbonate
usually studies will give around a 300
milligram per kilogram dose acutely and
that's kind of the typical
supplementation strategy the problem is
if you go a little bit too low it's
probably not gonna work and if you go a
little bit too high you might have some
very unpleasant gi side effects some
gastrointestinal discomfort that's
putting it lightly but it's a family
show we don't wanna get graphic but what
they did in this recent study is pretty
interesting
instead of doing 300 milligrams per
kilogram in a single dose they did 600
milligrams per kilogram but they spread
that over like in almost 20 hour period
with kind of repeated dosing along the
way what they found was they were able
to achieve the blood levels of
bicarbonate that they were hoping for
but without having that big influx
that's likely to potentially cause some
GI discomfort so I'll link that in in
the show notes and if you're interested
in looking at that supplementation
dosing protocol you can check that out
and see if it might be the strategy for
you now Greg you've got something here
and all it says as the title is hot
content I'm very excited to see what
that might be yeah I'm just gonna add
something really quick to the sodium
bicarbonate stuff sure so the the
mechanism by which sodium bicarbonate
works is it increases blood pH to some
degree so then as you produce hydrogen
ions during exercise they can they can
diffuse out of the muscle a little bit
more efficiently so you get a slower
drop in muscle PH which helps preserve
performance a little bit there was a
recent paper that came out maybe like
two months ago or so looking at the
effects of hyperventilating on on
exercise performance I reviewed that
study in Mass
but it's interesting so hyperventilating
is interesting because in theory it's
just a better version of by carbon and
supplementation so when you
hyperventilate you're blowing off more
carbon dioxide that induces a state
called respiratory alkalosis and
respiratory alkalosis can increase pH
slightly in both your blood and your
muscle tissue and so it basically is
it's kind of like a double dose of what
you'd be getting with my carbon and
supplementation so you can you can
buffer hydrogen ions within the muscles
a little bit better and then you can
also buffer hydrogen ions like you can
get a greater diffusion of hydrogen ions
into the blood once kind of pH of the
muscle starts dropping so it it has a
similar effect but it's kind of more
Universal so it's not just about the
difference in pH across that membrane
and so there's only a handful of studies
looking at it and it seems to be a
somewhat promising strategy so the study
guy reviewed in mass had had very
positive results and a couple priors in
that used resistance exercises like what
they were testing the effects on the
prior studies looked at I believe
cycling if memory serves and they had
kind of more mixed results the drawback
of hyperventilating as like a means of
improving strength like strength
endurance is that it seems like you kind
of have to find a Goldilocks zone where
if you hyperventilate too much you get
lightheaded perform worse and if you
maybe don't hyperventilate enough it's
not really gonna do much of anything but
it does seem that if you can kind of
find that Goldilocks zone of the
appropriate intensity of
hyperventilation and the appropriate
duration it actually seems to be pretty
effective so I'm not necessarily
recommending you do that but it might be
something worth playing around with for
exercises where you're not at that much
risk if you black out so you know maybe
give it a shot with like barbell rows or
curls or
I probably wouldn't actually matter for
curls but I don't know like Rose maybe
like Rd ELLs something like that so one
of the things Eric didn't mention about
bicarbonate supplementation and it's
something that I think maybe you should
keep in mind if you give it a shot is
like yes the thing people are most
concerned about and probably not aware
of as much as they should be is those GI
symptoms Eric mentioned they are very
real and they are very scary like you
know it's not gonna kill you or anything
but like while you're going through it
you'll wish you were dead
I have never been in more GI discomfort
than I was the first time I tried kind
of the standard dosing strategy of 300
milligrams per kilogram of baking soda
and my god by the time it worked its way
to the other end of my GI tract the
bathroom was a goddamn war zone like it
was it was a problem so that's something
that more people need to be aware of but
what Eric didn't mention is that sodium
bicarbonate I mean like dude if you've
if you grew up with parents of my
parents generation that maybe like had
you brush your teeth with baking soda
you know how bad baking soda tastes if
you haven't and you have some baking
soda in your pantry just like take a
spoonful of baking soda it doesn't taste
particularly good it's not it's not in
aggressively horrendous taste so like
the first time you taste it you might be
like yeah whatever this is generally
unpleasant but I could supplement with
it but the amount of sodium bicarbonate
you need to get down to have organic
affects is is pretty high so you know
compare it to caffeine where they
recommend three to six milligrams per
kilogram with sodium bicarbonate it's
300 milligrams per kilogram or 600
milligrams per kilogram spread out over
19 and a half hours so like if you're if
you're say a hundred kilos 220 pounds
if you go that 600 milligram route
spread out over 19 and a half hours
prior to exercise that's 60 grams of
sodium bicarbonate which is a lot of
sodium bicarbonate and the first time
you choke it down you may not hate it
too that much in protip if you go that
route dissolve it in hot water not cold
water it dissolves a lot better in in
hot water and you'll just be left with a
lot of grit if you go with cold water
but yeah you can choke it down the first
day and be like wow that was generally
unpleasant but I can stick with it but
by like your fourth or fifth day of
supplementing with that much sodium
bicarbonate you're gonna [ __ ] hate it
like it's it is one of the more
unpleasant supplements I have ever
experimented with just on a day-by-day
basis and that's the only reason I
mention hyperventilating because it's
it's not a perfect replacement by any
means like you'll you'll probably need
to do a fair amount of testing on
yourself to kind of dial in the
appropriate amount and there is some
risk maybe you'll get lightheaded I'm
not necessarily recommending you do that
but like by god if I were trying to get
these benefits and it was like okay
you're you either need to assume some
risk by trying to hyperventilate the
appropriate amount or you need to start
supplementing with sodium bicarbonate
every day I'm gonna roll the dice on
hyperventilating because it's just the
the day-to-day process of supplementing
with sodium bicarbonate is just
incredibly unpleasant yeah another thing
to keep in mind is it is also an
enormous dose of sodium so if you're
gonna be having it every day or before
every training session if you're someone
who not everybody genetically responds
the same way but if your blood pressure
is very responsive to a high sodium diet
that would probably not be the
supplementation strategy for you because
it's an enormous dose of sodium when
we're talking about orogenic doses it's
like 20 grams of sodium yeah its
enormous so so if you're sensitive if
your blood pressure tends to increase on
a high sodium diet that's gonna be a
problem and I will I will admit
I've actually never tried sodium
bicarbonate supplementation but a shot
dude so this I think that kills me
though like I don't want to forget to
mention this because it loops back to
the beat and come the the beat in
conversation I often write articles that
show which supplements may have our
genic effects and I think everybody
assumes that because they've been
conditioned by the supplement industry
like I'm either just a total piece of
[ __ ] who's just like cashing in on these
articles like oh yeah Eric wants me to
thank all supplements work or that I
personally use a ton of supplements
neither are true
you couldn't possibly buy a supplement
that would make me a penny and I
actually don't take that many day-to-day
at all so I think it's funny like if you
write an article that just gives an
honest appraisal of the literature and
just say like yeah there's evidence that
sodium bicarbonate might work I feel
like everybody just always assumes the
absolute worst but yeah I've never even
tried it yeah I mean I am I am very Pro
sodium bicarbonate might have beneficial
effects on strength endurance and very
anti sodium bicarbonate supplementation
exactly because it is there for you cuz
I cuz I've tried it and I gotta tell ya
I mean I very well might feel
differently if I ever compete in
strongman so at some point I think I'd
like to do a strongman show there's a
lot of like strength endurance type
skills being tested and strongman and I
would consider messing around with
sodium bicarbonate before event training
days to try to dial in my dosing
protocol to make sure I don't have
severe GI distress like on the actual
day of competition and I would consider
using it for a strongman competition
because like you could directly affect
my placing but and it would just be like
okay this is a strategy I am using for
competition and it is what it is like
sometimes like stuff you have to do to
compete isn't the most pleasant like I
don't like cutting weight I don't like
water cutting but you know if I'm like 5
pounds over my weight class I'll water
cut it's not fun but I do it and I would
view sodium bicarbonate
supplementation the same way but then if
there was like an alternate world where
I had the water cut before every
training session I would just never
train anymore because water cutting
[ __ ] sucks and I view sodium
bicarbonate supplementation the same way
like I would use it for competition I
you know grit my teeth and tough it out
but it is just so incredibly unpleasant
to supplement with on a day to day basis
that even though I think it is effective
and even though it might help my
performance in the gym a little bit I
would you could you would have to pay me
a substantial amount of money to
convince me to take it for all training
sessions yeah you did hit a little close
to home there with that water cut
metaphor wrestling with wrestling you
are actively training through a water
cut probably four or five sevenths of
the season like if you're in a pretty
challenging weight class I mean you
compete every Saturday and you're
starting to get pretty careful with your
water intake by like Tuesday you know
like you're thinking about it did you
did you not water load and then cut we
did but not intentionally I mean we were
just gotcha we would we would weigh in
on Saturday show up at school on Monday
just being a waterlogged puffy overfed I
mean it was just a mess yeah my
wrestling partner competed in the
hundred and thirty pound class dude he
would come in every Monday when we had
to win either on Friday or Saturday
every Monday he would come in 18 pounds
overweight at one at 1:30 dude that's
[ __ ] up yeah like he was losing an
enormous percentage of his body weight
every single week and unrelated
potentially I'm not sure if there was a
correlation he also threatened to quit
the team every Friday I think it might
have been he he would reach of his
absolute breaking point every Friday be
like I'm never doing this again and we
were like right but I mean in seven days
we are going to be right here doing the
same thing honestly that's absurd yeah
it was wild man
so I'm still very curious though you've
got this note in here that just says hot
content oh yeah so I've been working on
a project for the last couple of months
that I cannot give any details about and
if you ask I will refuse to give any
details about you'll find out eventually
I assume but one of the things we were
doing as part of that project is we were
kind of trying to characterize some just
like just like what group level stuff
looks like in our literature generally
and one of the things we were looking at
is something called Cohen's D Z so we've
talked about Cohen's D effect sizes on
on this podcast before we've written
about them on the website and a Cohen's
D effect size is essentially how large
the average change is relative to a
pre-training standard deviation so you
know if you're dealing with a group of
people that bench presses a hundred plus
or minus 20 pounds and the the mean
increase in bench press strength in a
study is 10 pounds then the Cohen's D
effect size is that 10 pound change
divided by the 20 pound standard
deviation or 0.5 so there is a similar
metric called Cohen's D Z which is
sometimes called a signal to noise
effect size where that is the change the
mean change divided by the standard
deviation of the change so in that same
example if they bench 100 plus or minus
20 pounds pre-training and their bench
presses increase by 10 plus or minus 5
pounds during training the Cohen's D
effect size is 0.5 the Cohen's D Z
effect size is the 10 pound mean change
divided by the 5 pound standard
deviation of the change or 2 so that
would be the Cohen's D Z and so one of
the things we wanted to see is kind of
within resistance training literature
how variable do gains and strength tend
to be so we found like a be some study
and unfortunately a minority of the
studies in our field actually report
Cohen's D Z effect sizes or just report
the variability in the change of
strength in the first place which is
pretty unfortunate but of those like 80
some studies about 20 of them are so
reported enough information to calculate
Cohen's DZ effect sizes and we found
that the average Cohen's D Z was about
1.6 and that was remarkably homogeneous
so occasionally we'd see studies that
reported Cohen's D Z values of around
one occasionally studies would report
Cohen's D Z values around 3 but for the
most part they were they were in like
the 1.25 to 2 range with an average of
1.6 and so we can use that information
to get an idea of like you know we're
not just gonna cherry-pick one study
where results are remarkably homogeneous
we're not just gonna cherry-pick one
study where results are remarkably
spread out but kind of across the entire
body of resistance training literature
at least like a good chunk of that
literature you can take the inverse of
the Cohen's D Z value to get an idea of
how spread out strength gains are in the
literature so the inverse of one point
six is 62 and a half percent or 0.625
and so what that tells you is if you
have an idea of how generally effective
something is on average for promoting
strength gains and we're talking about
like training interventions here that
tells you in general how how large of a
spread of results you should expect so
in other words to put actual numbers on
this if you know that a certain
intervention tends to improve someone's
squat by 20 pounds within one standard
deviation of that like you know about
two-thirds of the responses you should
expect to see very very normal responses
would be gains ranging from about seven
and a half pounds to about thirty two
and a half pounds and then if you want
to go one more standard deviation out
you should expect change
ranging from about negative five pounds
to forty five pounds so I I'm putting
those numbers out there because I think
that degree of variability is somewhat
surprising to people like I think when
people read research especially because
as I mentioned most studies don't report
the standard deviation of change scores
and so it's unless a study say has a
figure that shows all individual results
I think a lot of people aren't fully
aware of how variable training responses
are and so like I think a lot of people
kind of think about this for themselves
when they're training they see like Oh
on average people are improving by you
know maybe they put a hundred pounds in
there on their total in their second
year of training and I only put sixty
pounds on my total in my second year of
training am i broken and like no that's
that's incredibly normal that's
comfortably within one standard
deviation of the average that's not
something to be upset about and kind of
on the flip side it's like oh this we're
seeing someone who's gaining strength at
twice the rate of everyone else is that
suspicious like are they doing a [ __ ]
ton of drugs and not telling anyone it's
like well no like that's that's
comfortably within two standard
deviations of the mean if you're
starting to see people say gaining
strength are like five times the average
rate like yeah that's that's kind of
weird but anyway I think that's useful
information just to know for yourself as
a lifter or as a coach kind of degree of
variability you should expect to see
like how much variability is normal and
then also I I think this would be useful
for any like researchers listening to
this podcast if you're if you're
planning out some sort of training
intervention for a study and I don't
know that I told know that g-power
actually gives you the option to use
like Cohen's DZ to to plan this stuff
which is unfortunate but you could you
could do this by hand or I'm sure
there's like a package in our that does
this for you but if you're doing power
calculations and you're interested in
how large of a sample you should need to
recruit to see a significant mean effect
knowing the Cohen's D Z value will help
with that calculation so a Cohen's D Z
value of about one point six seems to be
standard for resistance training studies
so that's just a little piece of
information you can file a way for doing
power calcs on that topic I actually ran
a guy I came across a paper the other
day that was talking about doing power
calculations for interactions and it's
it was a really good paper I think it
was by Daniel Lake ins and Caldwell
maybe but it was very good and it was
kind of a kind of a tutorial type thing
where it walks you through like okay
what kind of an interaction are you
expecting because there's a couple
different ways to do it so if you are
currently sweating about a power
calculation that you're supposed to do
I'm gonna try to find that and put it in
the show notes because it was a very
good a very good paper very informative
I will say I always try to keep the
statistics talked to a minimum on the
show but every time we do it I get a lot
of positive feedback I feel like there's
an extremely vocal group of 16 people
out there who are just like come on
please do stat stuff today yeah we we
actually meme on ourselves and every
time we talk about statistics on the
showed the very next segment will be
like alright for the five people still
listening blah blah blah but we had
actually never gotten a complaint about
statistics talk on the podcast and we do
get a lot of positive feedback so this
may just become a statistics podcast
it's honestly the only positive feedback
I get and I'm not even kidding I think I
think the people who like it are so
worried that it's gonna go away that
when they hear it they're like okay I
gotta make sure that they know that we
like it alright well we're pretty deep
into the episode I
is probably time to play us out unless
there's a QA question you really wanted
to talk about now that's good with me
okay so we got a few off-topic questions
to play us out I know that people were
kind of fond of our fireside chat
episodes so we don't want to completely
abandon the off-topic questions
altogether this one killed me so this
was funny
Josh submitted this question to the
question portal it's what is it tiny dot
CC / SBS QA yes yeah so I'll just read
it verbatim
will you guys rescind your statements
about liking Rage Against the Machine
now that it's come out that they are
actually leftists I was shocked at this
news as as was my favorite conservative
icon Paul Ryan you guys are a bastion of
good Christian family values as
exemplified by Greg stellar stance on
sticky-icky which is unfortunately slang
for marijuana and that doesn't mesh with
Rage Against the Machine stronger by
science has been my church's favorite
Christian podcast and it would mean the
world to us so this was awesome
apparently with all of the political
stuff going on right now
I guess the backstory is that like I
think Tom Morello has been really vocal
about about politics or lately I mean he
always has what yeah yeah as has I mean
like holy [ __ ] if you don't if you don't
know where Zack de la Rocha stands on
political issues you've never seen an
interview was that Geller Rocha but yeah
so I think the back story I'm pretty
sure I heard something about this but
somebody like called out Tom Morello
like stick to the guitar riffs buddy
like we're not here for the politics and
like apparently a large number of people
just realized that Rage Against the
Machine if you look several layers
beneath the surface of their lyrics
there is some politically motivated
terminology in there a lot of people
were shocked to hear this but like not
even subtext no it is the most clear
thing like like man imagine when they go
back to their system of a down records
you know they might also get some
of political commentary there but no I
mean like Rage Against the Machine I
think if you were to ask them they would
say that we're a political action
committee who also plays music correct
you know what I mean like well the whole
reason the band well not the whole
reason but one of the main reasons the
band broke up is like they're anarchists
like that's that is their their
political sway and they were hoping they
could make music for the revolution and
you know throughout the 90s like that
was I don't think there has ever been in
era in American politics more
characterized than political complacency
and like they basically just like black
killed themselves because they're like
we're trying to wake people up to the
liked all of the bad stuff going on in
the world and like they come and jam out
to our records and then don't go out in
the world and actually do anything and
so like yeah one of the reasons they
split up is because like they're like
well this this obviously hasn't been an
effective political strategy I guess we
should move on and do something else
yeah I mean it just kills me because
they're apparently there was a bunch of
people who were just like man I don't
think I can listen to them anymore
knowing that they lean left I had no
idea yeah and I like that this commenter
mentioned Paul Ryan because like in an
interview and maybe 2014 or so the
interviewer asked Paul Ryan like what
kind of music he was into and he said
his favorite band was Rage Against the
Machine and Tom Morello just came out it
was just like [ __ ] you you are the
Machine we're raging against don't
listen to our music anymore and like
it's shocking to me like how could how
could Paul Ryan like Rage Against the
Machine it's honestly surprising I don't
know so we've got another off-topic
question this one hits close to home
today the two questions that we got
about just generally being night owls
and consuming coffee the two kind of
tend to be related in many cases but so
the first question I don't know how to
pronounce that name how would you
pronounce that name ci
and see on that sounds good to me
but the question is you know they
sometimes I have to stay up late working
and their focus tends to drop off so
what do we do to be able to work late at
night and still kind of stay focused and
be productive the other question
same-same person asked this question as
well given that we work pretty long days
we like coffee what's our favorite way
of drinking coffee
they mentioned their favorite is
Aeropress they said this question is
only for Greg mostly because based on my
cookie and eating habits they're
assuming that I just eat spoonfuls of of
instant coffee which is actually not
true but in any case the reason I say
this hits close to home today this is
kind of our busy time a month I did
happen to be up to like 4:00 a.m. last
night and so you might have noticed a
couple Easter eggs in the podcast
episodes such as when I said that a car
might be missing two out of its three
hubcaps should have been four you know
so yeah there is something I'm starting
to think that potentially sleep
deprivation might influence mental
acuity to some extent but if I don't
read the research I'll never have to
confront it so that that's a good thing
so Greg when you're working late at
night how do you stay focused and then
you can also answer the question about
about coffee as well yeah so for staying
focused at night one it's not that hard
for me mostly because like I do have a
relatively extreme circadian rhythm I
feel I'm probably a little bit more
degenerate with my sleep cycle than I
should be but like I've tested this
multiple times throughout my life at
various points in my life and I do find
that I personally feel best when I go to
bed at 3:00 or 4:00 and wake up
somewhere between 11:00 and 1:00 so
that's not what I'm currently doing like
I am keeping kind of a more normal sleep
schedule actually but I I do
consistently feel better when I when I
am on that later schedule
and so like if it's just like I'm
working up until 2 or 3 a.m. that's not
hard like that's that's when I feel good
I have also talked about how I'm quite a
fan of stimulants in general and one of
the things that helps me work up to that
point
in in the evening and not just like
completely ruin my sleep is after after
probably like 4 p.m. or so like 3 or 4
p.m. I'll switch over from caffeine to
nicotine because nicotine has a has a
shorter half-life and so I find that
like you know if I'm working to 4:00
a.m. and I have a cup of coffee or an
energy drink or something at midnight or
1:00 a.m. I do have a lot of issues
getting to sleep you know when I go to
bed 2 or 3 hours later and I find that
it impacts how long it takes to get to
sleep my quality of sleep I'll feel
tired or the next day whereas since
nicotine has a shorter half-life I can
use that up to about an hour hour and a
half before I go to bed and I find that
it doesn't impact how long it takes me
to fall asleep there's some research
suggesting that it could impact sleep
quality I haven't you know done like a
sleep study to see if like objectively
my sleep quality's worse but it feels
like it's fine and I still wake up
feeling good and rested so yeah like
just a combination of having kind of a
naturally extreme circadian rhythm and
switching over from caffeine to nicotine
later in the day helps me work late at
night and and be productive and still
sleep well you know with me when it
comes to trying to stay focused late at
night one of the things I try to do is I
think it's very difficult to force focus
and so what I try to do is eliminate the
need to do so so for example if I'm like
okay this literally must be done
tonight before I go to sleep but I am
not in a place to focus right now I'll
take a little walk or maybe I'll take a
short nap you know but but I won't just
stare at the screen until my eyes bleed
and say come on Eric focus because that
just doesn't seem to work very well in
my experience so what I try to do is you
know if I'm trying to make it work but
it doesn't necessarily have to be done
that night then I'll say just cut it go
to bed pick it up in the morning you'll
have more efficient work in the morning
and it'll be better work so ultimately
that that's a net positive but if it
must get done that night like I said
I'll say listen you don't have the focus
right now and that's okay let's take a
walk let's grab a snack let's take a nap
let's do whatever we have to do to to
get to the point where we have that
focus and at a certain point you can't
necessarily stimulant your way there you
know especially like getting
overstimulated is not a good thing for
focus right I mean that it gets even
even more challenging for me if I'm like
listen I'm just going to drink coffee
you know more and more and more and more
then I struggle to focus just because
the stimulation levels did too high
so so that might be helpful what about
coffee great what's what's your go-to
for coffee how you make it yeah so I
also use an arrow press I I use an arrow
press because my light my my wife likes
an arrow press I'm not particularly
picky when it comes to coffee this this
may offend people listening to this
episode but I don't love coffee I guess
I find it generally inoffensive I don't
dislike it but yeah I mean it's fine it
has caffeine that's the main thing I
drink it for I do I do prefer the coffee
that comes out of a narrow press to just
like a drip coffee maker like I do think
it tastes better but I still don't love
it I mean I'm drinking it for the
caffeine and yeah I don't know I'm I am
the farthest thing possible from a
coffee snob so I do like Aeropress
coffee but my opinion
is not one that should particularly
matter you know for me I do like coffee
quite a bit so I think the attention I
pay to the quality of my coffee and my
beer he's way different from the way
that I view food like food I'm like
whatever all eat I'll eat whatever is
available coffee and beer though I do
like to have nice things but when it
comes to coffee I did at one point try
to get into using the French press I was
like I'm gonna step it up a notch and I
just didn't like it as much I don't know
I like drip coffee but but I tried to
actually the grocery store I go to their
store brand the grounds that they you
know the coffee beans that are kind of
pre ground that you can get they're
pretty damn good like they're there in
my opinion a major step up from like the
Maxwell House and Folgers that got me
through grad school so that that has
been the main extent of my lifestyle
creep post grad school as I've moved up
from the absolute cheapest coffee you
could possibly get to the second
cheapest coffee tier you could possibly
get but for me based on my food habits
that's a huge step now I agree like
Folgers maxwell house is just absolutely
terrible one of the things i'm fond of
saying is if the best part of waking up
is folders in your cup you should talk
to a therapist like you've got you've
got some some issues to work through
yeah that i think that's true and i
think that's probably a great way to end
the show so that does it for this week's
episode like I said we've got one more
episode before our summer break that
episode is going to be coming out on
July 2nd until then take care and we'll
talk to you soon thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
health care professional
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to support it visit stronger by
science comm to check out the products
and services that we offer thanks for
listening and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you